you could switch skill sets with any
teammate for a day who would you choose
and why Joe or Nicholas baton one
because Nicholas Bon is tall you know he
can play defense he can get his shots
off really quickly and then joah because
he he's joah okay one teammate to be
stranded on a deserted island with I'm
going say either Pat Bev or Tobias P if
we going to if we had to go hunt and get
something somebody want on my side and
Tobias is going to come up with some
strategy to I don't know save our lives
and I know he's going to figure it out
somehow if you could go one-on-one
against any player in NBA history who
would you choose probably Dwayne W best
trash you've ever faced Draymond
probably I think Anthony is a good trash
talker too Philly athlete Mount Rushmore
does rocky count Rocky can count yeah
why not so Alan Iverson Dr J I'm going
say Donovan McNab Bryce Harper I say
Joel will be on there as well if you
could have any song play when you hit a
shot what song would it be and why
probably something with the Temptations
cuz I like The Temptations